it's the little things so this is gonna
be a new occasional series that I'm
gonna do as i it it into the schedule
and when i'm not bogged down with other
stuff so nitpick rants and it is exactly
what it sounds like sometimes there's
something in a movie maybe it's a movie
that i am beyond in the first place
maybe it's movie i love but there's
something about it some tiny little
thing that I'm like that's driving me
crazy and it's in these are nitpicks
these are things that are too small to
ever bring up in a actual review I mean
not that I do a ton of reviews but you
know these aren't the sort of things
that you would ever bring up in any sort
of analysis of the overall film or TV
show or whatever I end up talking about
it's just these little things that drive
me nuts and we're gonna start with a
movie that I like quite a bit and that
is the force awakens and let's talk
about Chewie and Chewy's fingers so we
have seen Chewbacca on screen for oh god
about 40 years now and he's big he's
scruffy he's lovable he's been tweaked a
little bit his hair you know sort of the
way they've handled the hair directly on
his head has changed a little bit from
time to time but he's always had that do
one of its shaggy dog look I mean that's
that's what he looked at he's a big
shaggy dog in the screen and sort of an
odd thing that I had never thought about
till they messed it up was his hands and
we never saw his fingers we never saw
individual digits you know we obviously
must have had them he was handling stuff
and he was doing technical work on the
Millennium Falcon he was fixing stuff so
obviously somewhere under that mass of
hair he's got fingers fine but we never
saw them and then force awakens
we got this first time they showed his
his fingers when he's putting a bomb
down and we saw the glue you see him
press this button I I was in the fear
wasn't good huh and then they showed his
hands like pressing the the thing like
why wait you I mean kids that that did
so much to break the illusion because
not only have we never seen his fingers
before
like we're eight glove fingery and
things and it's just it broke the
illusion I mean I never liked it my head
broke down wookie Anatomy I didn't know
whether he had a par whether they had a
human-like hand but it's like it looks
long and I hate it I Hey every single
time those scenes come up and you know
he's planning to bomb and then he
triggers the thing ah hey I don't want
to see Julie's fingers I never want to
see them again like how is how is that
necessary I understand for the actions
they showed like maybe they thought they
needed to show his fingers but all he
had to do was show the [ __ ] hang in
place the bomb and it comes away in the
bombs they're blinking you see the the
trigger thing in his big shaggy hand you
just see him sort of do emotion we don't
need the articulation of the fingers
just your Chum big shaggy hand and the
result of what the thing is I don't need
to see these weird black AAP fingering
things on chewie they shouldn't be there
no get them off take them away so that
is a tiny little thing that is in a
movie I like that really bugs the heck
out of me so that's it for this nitpick
rant was this something that bugged you
or did I just ruin the movie for you or
do you think I'm psychotic whatever your
thoughts are drop something out in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter I council of geeks giblets in
the Council of geese podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]